es ist früh am Morgen in London und ich
habe Hunger und was könnte mein Hunger
besser sättigen als ein full English
Breakfast nicht irgendwo sondern beim
besten Laden der Stadt Los geht's ach
wunderschön was für ein Tag oder guck da
ist er
doch fre
breakp Perf
reger English
breakf los geht breakfast im Regency
Café Laden sieeh so geil aus von dem was
wir online gesehen haben ich bin
gespannt ob wir filmen dürfen vielleicht
haben die Betreiber Lust uns ein
bisschen was zu erzählen es wird sehr
sehr
[Musik]
gut ich jetzt so full English breakfast
was stelle ich mir darunter vor auf
jeden Fall natürlich sehr fettig also
man hat die Bratwürste man hat den Bacon
Hash Browns also wirklich es ist im
Prinzip eine Frechheit das ein Frühstück
zu nennen weil wenn du das frühstückst
dann ist schon wieder vorbei aber genau
das will ich heute dann natürlich die
BAK beans Champignons und Black pding
das ist ja die Blutwurst sehr kontrovers
wahrscheinlich der kontroverseste
Bestandteil von dem Gericht aber ich bin
heute offen für alles ich will die
komplette authentische Erfahrung haben
als wir letztens in London waren hat
einfach der Rezeptionist so gefragt was
ich mache weil wir auch mit Kamera
rumgelaufen sind meint er so hey Justin
folgt dir und wir sind einfach so in
fucking London am anderen Ende der Welt
und der rezensionist sagt so diger wie
krank dir folg Justin so Justin so mein
mein day one aber sehr krass der hat auf
jeden Fall geschafft wir sollten jeden
Moment da sein ich hoffe das ist jetzt
keine Schlange oder so aber wir sind
sehr untouristisch hier von der Region
her ALR thank you so much ge ich habe so
Lust darauf jetzt Alter oh mein
Gott es hat sich scheinb rumgesprochen
kebabland von englischem Frühstück die
Leute da drin sind so perfekt der Laden
ist wirklich alles was wir uns wünschen
könnten man hört die nur brüllen da drin
Essen fertig so geil die Leute die da
sitzen essen h English
breakfast
[Musik]
ohne Witz Leute ich habe das Gefühl wir
sind einfach
so in die Essenz von London von UK
reingestäufert wir stehen hier in diesem
Laden total busy von jedem der hier
sitzt könnte man gefühlt so ein Portrait
machen so weißt du das ist einfach geil
und es gibt diese Läden dazu zählt
kebabland in Köln dazu zählt Fard in
Wien die die die vibrieren einfach so
die haben so viel Leben und du merkst
einfach so du bist richtig und hier hat
man das es gibt längst nicht nur
Englisch breakfast sondern es gibt halt
alles mögliche ne also es gibt ja so
einfaches Essen was schon fast so ein
bisschen wie Kantinenessen aussieht aber
ich glaube dass es auf ganzer Linie
überzeugen wird I find the full English
breakfast on the menu it two cups of tea
hier wurde der Film von Elon John
gefilmt okay wir müssen einen Platz
finden da ist es doch ich weiß nicht ob
mich das Essen mehr begeistert oder die
ganze Atmosphäre hier es ist wirklich
ein Laden wie aus einem Film und er ist
auch aus einem Film z.B der Elton John
Film Rocketman wurde hier gedreht habe
ich auch gerade erst von der Bedienung
erfahren und es fühlt sich wirklich
authentisch an es fühlt sich ehrlich an
es fühlt sich geschichtsträchtig an wenn
wir uns hier umschauen diese Fliesen an
der Wand sind noch von
1946 und der ganze Laden ist anscheinend
ich habe gerade selbst n gegoogelt im
Art Deco Style gehalten scheinbar finde
ich Art Deco Style sehr geil weil dieser
Laden sieht wirklich fassbar gut aus
dieses Essen hier allerdings auch also
es ist wirklich schwer in Worten zu
fassen wie es sich anfühlt jetzt gerade
hier zu sein ich dachte wir gehen
English Breakfast Essen das war's aber
es ist wirklich viel mehr als das das
ist eine richtig geile Erfahrung an den
Wänden hängen Fotos von Muhammad Ali mit
handschriftlichen Texten drunter war der
hier vielleicht keine Ahnung Tottenham
hotsfur Spieler waren da und alleine so
diesen Orangensaft in diesen geilen
Morgenlicht einzuschenken das ist
einfach nicht normal freue mich einfach
hier zu sein und auf das Essen freue ich
mich auch ich persönlich bin nämlich ein
riesen Fan von English Breakfast und wir
haben alles was wir dafür brauchen wir
haben an allererster Stelle black
Pudding also diese Blutwurst die mit ich
glaube Weizen gemacht wird natürlich mit
Blut und so weiter und so fort dann
haben wir Hash Browns Dreiecke aus
Kartoffeln am ehsten zu vergleichen mit
unseren Kartoffelrösti dann haben wir
natürlich ein paar Champignons die auch
natürlich in sehr sehr viel Butter
gebraten werden Baked Beans dürfen auf
gar keinen Fall fehlen Tomaten in der
Mitte halbiert und auf der
schnittfächeri eine sausage also eine
Bratwurst würden wir sagen Bacon das ist
aber ein bisschen anders als der Bacon
den man aus dem amerikanischen Frühstück
kennt und ein over easy egg das erkennen
wir daran dass es quasi von oben auch
ein bisschen gegart ist lass uns bitte
einfach anfangen ich glaube ich will zu
allererst für dieses Feeling in die
Baked Beans reingehen wahrscheinlich
kommen die so wie sie sind aus einer
Dose aber genauso muss es
sein so schmeckt für mich England also
diese Tomatensoße dieses klebrige es ist
einfach wenn man hier und jetzt gerade
sitzt ist es einfach richtig ich denke
es gibt viele da draußen die einzelne
Bestandteile davon gar nicht mögen
würden tut mir leid für euch weil ihr
verpasst was die sausage dazu gibt's
natürlich die Brown Sauce die man sich
an einem soßenspender so viel man will
drauf machen kann ich probier erstmal
mit
Ketchup wow irgendwas macht dieser Ort
hier mit mir bin vor vielen Jahren mit
Luca gemeinsam durch UK gereist also
nicht nur durch England sondern wir
waren auch in Wales und da habe ich
jeden Morgen English Breakfast gegessen
und das so lange her und irgendwie bin
ich genau in diese Zeit gerade
zurückversetzt also das war einfach so
ich habe es einfach genossen ich hat
keine Sorgen es war alles geil und das
fühle ich gerade wenn ich dieses
Frühstück hier vor mir stehen habe und
das ist einfach genau das Ding so essen
kann so emotional sein weil ich glaube
das Setting macht gerade alles hätte ich
das in irgendeinem
hässlichen hässlichen Hinterhof
Restaurant
bekommen aber es ist einfach
besonders irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl
wenn man hier nur über das Essen reden W
würde man dem Laden gar nicht gerecht
werden weil der ist viel mehr als das
Essen hier ist der Bacon man sagt zu
English Breakfast auch Fry ab also quasi
einfach alles einmal durchfritieren oder
durchbraten und genau das findet sich
auf dem Teller wieder Bacon mit HP Sauce
ich lieb es einfach gefühlt leert sich
der Laden jetzt ein bisschen und wir
haben wirklich riesiges Glück dass wir
überhaupt hier Filmen dürfen steht ein
riesiges Schild hier bitte nicht filmen
die Dame die so dezent schreit im
Hintergrund die war so nett und hat uns
doch filmen lassen bin sehr sehr happy
darum weil das mit euch teilen zu können
fühle ich ab finde was den Laden hier so
besonders macht ist dass es ein Laden
für alle ist das beginnt natürlich mit
den Preisen die für Londoner
Verhältnisse unfassbar fair sind eine
Tasse Tee kostet z.B 1,5€ Eier sausages
und Baked Beans Kosten 3 € 3 € 3 p 15 es
ist einfach ein Laden der ist real so
und hier trifft sich auch die ganze
Gesellschaft so wir hatten jemand vor
uns in der Schlange dem es
offensichtlich nicht so gut ging dann
hast du Leute die im Anzug hier sitzen
du hast aber auch Prominente die
vorbeikommen und du hast erstaunlich
wenig Touristen also man man hört alle
Leute nur British English reden weil es
einfach glaube ich so ein echter
Geheimtipp ist und gerade auch so mit
Geschichten wie den Black Pudding ist ja
auch nicht für jeden was die klassisch
englische Küche den wollen wir jetzt
einmal probieren ich weiß nicht wie sich
das so von der beispielsweise reinischen
Blutwurst unterscheidet aufgeschnitten
auf der Schnittkante gebraten wie H es
anders sein sollen wahrscheinlich mit
ordentlich Öl ich probi
mal fast ein bisschen milder sehr
speziell ich verstehe jeden der es nicht
mag aber ich mag es echt gerne du kannst
dir drei Tage seit Zen sparen wenn du
hier warst weil ich glaub du hast mehr
das Gefühl in London gewesen zu sein
wenn du hier gesessen hast und
gefrühstückt hast als wenn du ein Big B
towerbdge London irgendwo standest wir
probieren jetzt noch die mushrooms ich
brauch nicht sagen das sind die besten
Pilze meines Lebens oder die besten
Baked Beans meines Lebens aber es ist
das beste English Breakfast meines
Lebens weil es einfach ein besonderer
Ort ist es schmeckt einfach geil ich bin
einfach hier dazu gibt's diesen Tee den
wir hier trinken ein Tee der aussieht
wie Kaffee genau weil natürlich
klassisch briittisch wird er mit Milch
getrunken der wird in diesen riesigen
Kannen hier vorne gekocht die hauen
einfach das Tee Pulver rein schütten
heißes Wasser drauf und dann gibt's das
hier das so ein bisschen wie Espresso in
Italien ich glaub Tee in England ist
immer
gut dieser her sieht übelst Standard aus
als ob du den so einfach kaufen könntest
vielleicht ist er auch sogar gekauft
aber ich find hier in dieser Szenerie
ist der
einfach ja der schmeckt einfach krasser
der schmeckt einfach besser dieser Laden
ist nicht nur kulinarisch ein Traum
sondern auch für mich so wie ein
spielplatzter wirklich ich einmal quer
durch full English Breakfast
durchgetestet und irgendwie irgendwie
war unfassbar geil ich hätte gar nicht
gedacht dass so geil ist und wir haben
überlegt ist das ein Video Wert so hier
English Breakfast zu essen und ich habe
gesagt ich habe einfach Bock darauf so
ich will dieses full English Breakfast
essen wir wurden so belohnt dafür es war
wirklich ein absoluter Traum deshalb man
kann es einfach nicht anders sagen das
ist ein must visit wenn ihr in London
seid thank was für ein absoluter Traum
so wird Zeit wieder die normale Welt zu
betreten das war wirklich eine krasse
Sache und wir hätten beide nicht
erwartet dass uns das so abholen würde
das war wirklich wie aus dem Bilderbuch
kommt h einfach vorbei ich glaube ich
habe es oft genug gesagt Regency CAF in
der Nähe von Westminster Hall ist
einfach ist einfach ein Traum bin ich
fast ein bisschen traurig dass wieder
nach Deutschland
geht